we have a voicemail number you can call
that number anytime
that number is 2192
davidp 2192
davidp here is a delightful caller
monday i'm trying to keep it positive
with delightful callers
this is a delightful caller who got
coveted multiple times she says
and is just thrilled to finally be
vaccinated take a listen
hey david this is nancy from utah and i
just wanted to tell you how excited i
was to get my vaccine
um i got covered twice i wrote positive
once in september and once in january
and got quite sick both times so i was
thrilled to go get my vaccine i couldn't
be more pleased
to finally not have to worry about covet
again i must be some kind of freaky kova
magnet
love your show bye-bye thank you so much
i'm so glad to hear that i'm really
sorry that you had covered twice
um listen we've we have the tools my
friends we have the tools to crush this
virus we have vaccines that work against
the variants we've just got to use them
and we've got to use them quickly
and we'll have an update a little bit
later this week
about where we are as far as vaccines go
but
things i i know that there's still a lot
of doom and gloomers
but europe is opening travel is
restarting
kids are going back to school in the
fall uh
college students uh at many schools will
be required to be vaccinated there are
some businesses now saying our employees
will have to be
vaccinated to come back and uh do
in-person
work um we look at the numbers that
we're seeing
in countries that are achieving even
modest levels of vaccination look at our
cases
we've only fully vaccinated 37 percent
in the united states
okay and we are crushing the the numbers
they're still too high but they're the
lowest they've been in a really long
time
we are probably
20 days from being at 50 fully
vaccinated
look at what happened in israel when
they got to 50
fully vaccinated there are good things
coming up
and we should all be happy about that
and we should all follow cdc guidelines
as i continue to do we have a great
bonus show for you today
the house republican uh house
republicans many house republicans
are being fined more and more money
for not wearing their masks which are
still required on the house floor
marjorie taylor green
has been fined and others have been
fined will they pay the fines is the
question we're going to talk about that
um a viral video well known to many in
our audience
on youtube is leaving youtube and
instead will be
selling as an nft a non-fungible token
is this the future of youtube videos
very interesting and lastly
rick santorum has been fired by cnn
and it was over those comments where he
was caught saying
uh there was nothing of value here in
the united states
when the european settlers arrived like
other than all those native american
civilizations
very ugly and also non-real uh
not non-empirically based comments and
cnn has now fired rick santorum
republicans are saying it's cancelled
culture
canceled sort of like they did to liz
cheney for saying
trump really lost so we are going to
talk about that
on the bonus show as well become a
member
today to get instant access by signing
up at joinpackman.com
or we're only one week away from our
memorial day membership
bomb single day membership special
be notified of it by signing up
at davidpakman.com for my newsletter
monday morning
the 31st you'll get a beautiful email
from me personally
saying hey you know what here's how you
do it
here's how you sign up for that hugely
discounted membership all right we'll
talk to you on the bonus show in mere
moments
we are here all week we are off monday
memorial day i'm gonna be so busy
processing these massive membership
dumps we can't possibly do a show no and
we like giving the staff
uh federal holidays off all right see
everybody on the bonus show
or tomorrow